when you're in love with someone you're
going to organize your schedule
and make them a priority people get what
they accept people get what they
tolerate in themselves and each other
what do you do when you're growing and
the person that it might be the most
important person in your life
isn't growing with you it's a huge
problem
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
foreign
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn
seven ways to improve your relationship
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one pick the right person to be with
with tom billiard
i want to start with one of the things
that you have
always said is like the base and
foundation to relationships
selection matters so that's where i want
to start
um talk to me about selection matters
what you mean by that
so this is i feel so bad because for a
long time it didn't dawn on me how
important it was and i just thought that
i was like
king [ __ ] in relationships um and then
i really started to think about the way
that you are in the relationship and how
would i be able to
um apply the things that i'm learning
from reading books and all of that stuff
about how to make a relationship work if
you weren't
so adept at one just being good
at communicating too
you're so good at letting things go and
realizing how much grace you were giving
me in the relationship to make mistakes
to try things that didn't necessarily
work or to just be plain young and
stupid
i don't remember when it hit me but i
remember how it felt when i was like
wait a second
if i didn't have that then all of the
knowledge and tools and tactics wouldn't
go anywhere if you didn't have a growth
mindset as well then this would really
be sort of dead in the water and
it really made me start to reflect on
how much of this is actually that i have
tools and tactics and how much of this
is that i just really chose
wisely and really began to realize you
need both for sure you need the tools
you need the tactics you need
communication the hard work that you
were talking about in the intro
all of that's real but you really need
to
pick somebody that has certain sort of
objective universal characteristics
like um either already a growth mindset
or a willingness to pursue it i mean we
got together so young and i think either
i know neither of us had a growth
mindset but we understood very early on
that you either grow together or you
grow apart
uh so we put equal energy into
improving and then there are things that
are specific to you there are certain
things you're going to like
not like the fact that we're not both
you know just sort of alphas banging our
heads together
that we found a nice yin yang balance
like you were talking about way number
two
prioritize the relationship with jordan
peterson how to make a relationship work
like it's not just magic
you need to kind of put in the work to
make it work it's hard you should put it
in effort and yeah
compromise a lot of times on like if you
live by yourself you can do everything
the way you would want
yeah if you live with someone else then
there's compromises to make
yes in the long picture it's better for
you well that's that's it that's it
there's sacrifices to be made in the
short term
yeah you know and i mean people have to
the effort issue is like
well when you're in love with someone
you're going to organize your schedule
and make them a priority and you know
that's
in some ways a fleeting state although
it's not necessarily as fleeting as
people think it is but whatever
it's it's obviously a priority then you
get married and
you know you kind of get accustomed to
having each other around and then
everything else is more important and
the relationship drifts to the bottom
and then people get dissatisfied and
they start looking for excitement and
venture otherwise well
you can't do that you have to prioritize
the relationship like
my observation clinically has been for a
couple to maintain their relationship
without it deteriorating they have to
spend 90 minutes a week together talking
about their lives
about how the is run about what they've
all been doing to keep their stories
caught up right
it's not really even that much but no
it's not it's not
it's not that much yeah but but and
which is a good thing you can actually
do it and then they need to spend at
least
one time having
a date and two is better one is
necessary two is better you can't aim
for a lot more than that because
you know life is very busy and yeah if
it's going to be sustainable it has to
be realistic
but they need to make time for each
other twice a week and
and talk in like in a non-romantic
way just practically about the domestic
economy and about everything that's
going on
and that keeps people tied to each other
and updated and so that's sort of your
minimal commitment level if you don't
want things to deteriorate
way number three understand and
appreciate each other with tony and sage
robbins
people get what they accept people get
what they tolerate in themselves and
each other and most people in a
relationship are thinking about what
they're going to tolerate the other
person but
in our relationship i think the beauty
and the passion and all the juice that
i've gotten experience
in our relationship with my girl is
because i hold myself to a higher
standard than she could ever expect of
me
and i think when your standard and focus
is about yourself instead about your
partner about how do i show up more what
am i here to give
in the beginning of a relationship
people's whole focus is how do i light
them up i want to do anything that
lights them up and it makes you feel
incredible like your partner up
and you know relationship is aging not
based on years
but based on one you can be with
somebody a week but if you start
thinking about what are they doing for
me and
i'm doing it all you start measuring
what you're giving
instead of just giving from your heart
and your soul things drop off so
maybe this week is a chance for you to
really create some relationship
breakthroughs and we think that takes
three things any kind of breakthrough
sometimes it's having the right strategy
because frankly you know as a guy
we say and do things that girls
interpret very differently
they come up with very different
meanings and vice versa you know
for men for example problems are not
things you talk about
problems are things you solve right now
or you make them small and move on for
ladies
sharing that problem digging in feeling
it not solving it understanding it
understanding gentlemen is such a key
piece we are
such different species and i think
having an understanding of each other
and each other's needs
and knowing that we are not the same you
know our own reality of how we think and
feel and process life is isn't the same
for your partner
so having that not just understanding
but truthfully appreciation for how they
view and experience the world is a game
changer is it game tree there's so many
things in our relationship and it's like
oh my goodness you know what
it's not me because sometimes you take
things personally it's just knowing that
that's how they process reality and
process life when they say that it's not
meant for mars women for venus john
gray's a friend of mine that's a
wonderful approach but
all men have a feminine side and a
masculine side all women have a feminine
side and a masculine side
it's really just understanding how this
species their different species
interpret the world
and if you don't understand the strategy
of how to interpret that you'll be upset
or angry or frustrated so perhaps this
week uh
and you know you'll be able to dig in
and get some new understandings that'll
take some of the weight off and make you
laugh at stuff
that you used to get upset about way
number four get to know
other people's goal with brendan
burchard everybody wants better
relationships because you and i both
know when your relationship sucks
your life sucks but a ton of people have
terrible relationships and they don't
know why
and they're constantly fighting and
they're always in the argument mode
they're always like
thinking the other person isn't
sufficient isn't delivering for them
isn't happy for them
isn't supportive enough and so you have
all these people who have
like good people in their lives but
their relationships suck
and sometimes the relationship sucks
with their family or their friends or it
can be their significant other
and it's like it makes you want to tear
your hair out so let me give you four
ideas that can actually help you improve
your relationships
nurturing deeper better relationships
with anybody
right friends family or your significant
other your partner your lover
so the first idea is you never know a
person
if you don't know their goals and if you
don't know their goals
you're never going to be a great friend
you'll never be their great lover
their great supporter their great family
member
and it's weird though because most
people actually don't know other
people's goals i'll ask family members
to say
what what's your sister's goals you know
she wants to be a dancer okay what kind
of dancer
when what does she want to do with that
career it's the short term is a long
term like
you have to really get into people's
goals to understand their heart
and so that's what i want you to do is
if you want to be a great spouse to
somebody
you got to re-engage and say hey what do
you want at this stage of your life
because i know i know what you used to
want then we had kids but where are you
at now
and you got to get that conversation
with your partner and say hey listen
i know we've been through a couple of
weird months where we just haven't
really
felt each other out it's like let's just
do some personal development
like what do you really want to do right
now at this stage of your life because
you have to understand
when i say this stage of your life
that's very specific
meaning a lot of people's goals change
and it changes like every three months
every year every three years so if you
haven't had the conversation
with the important people in your life
recently about what your goals are
and about what their goals are then i'm
telling you you're just skimming at the
surface
because if you don't support other
people's dreams how can you ever have a
deep relationship with them
and if you don't share your dreams and
your heart and your desire with other
people
how can they possibly help you meet that
hunger how can they possibly
help you become the best version of you
if you haven't shared it
so you also have to be very honest with
what's your real thoughts what's your
real feelings what's your real dreams
what do you really want at this stage of
your life
with all the important people around you
it's one of my favorite things to do
with high performers to say
okay do all the people around you know
what you really want right now
are they clear on what your goals are
are they clear about how they can
support that or how much you want them
to be involved in it
it's like a lot of people start their
own business but they don't tell the
other people around them
what that business is what it requires
how they love their support
and so we all go it alone and isn't
going it alone the opposite of having
healthy supportive relationships so
first thing you got to do if you want
better relationships
get to know other people's goals all
right my friend evan carmichael's book
listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
way number five open up with your
partner with mel roberts
you're in a relationship and you've
spent the last couple months
really working on yourself right you've
been going to the gym
you've been reading all these incredible
books you've got a gratitude journal
maybe you're even about to launch your
own business and so you're growing and
you're happy
and yet there's a major problem and the
problem is that the person that you're
in love with
they're not interested in personal
development at all what do you do
what do you do when you're growing and
the person that
might be the most important person in
your life isn't growing with you
it's a huge problem a huge problem and
i want to break it apart for you because
this
is not something that is going to get
fixed overnight and it's something that
you can have a direct impact on and it's
also something that can become very
serious so i want you to pay attention
first of all you got to understand
you cannot change somebody else you can
budget them
you can threaten them you can guilt them
but at the end of the day it is up to
the person that you're with to decide
whether or not he or she
is going to change that said you can do
things
that influence whether or not they want
to and so
the most important thing with personal
development now remember what's the key
word in personal development
it's personal is you continue to do you
you continue to read the books you
continue
to hang out with the people that inspire
you you continue to push your life
forward you continue to go to the gym
and the thing that you're going to do is
you're going to share a lot with your
partner you're going to share about what
you're learning
you're going to share about who you're
hanging out with you're going to share
about all these cool distinctions and
tools that you're learning
you're going to share about the things
that scare you you're going to
open up in a way that impacts
your relationship the thing you're not
going to do is you're not going to tell
them they have to do it too
because the second that you tell
somebody to do something they're going
to say no
you may invite them hey i'm gonna go
hang out with so-and-so you want to come
you can ask them if they'd be interested
in reading things you can
ask them questions but what you don't
want to do is you don't
want to tell them what to do because
it's going to totally backfire
way number six don't look for fairy
tales with marisa pierre
you see fairy tales cause a lot of
problems because they again
overexpose us to something that is not
real we have this
incorrect actually harmful belief that
you will meet your other half
and they'll complete you but you're not
a half you're a whole and when you're a
whole you're not looking for someone to
complete
you're looking for someone to grow a
relationship with
and here's the biggest problem of all
this belief that
your other half will meet all your needs
so i'm here to tell you that simply is
not true imagine you have needs we all
have needs
your partner can probably meet a third
of your needs
very well and another third you need to
meet them
yourself and the third third well you
might have to let them go imagine you
need is to have a
perfect home with white sofas and a
white carpet and everything tied away
you've got three kids
who like to play football often you have
to look at you and think well you know
that need just isn't going to work i
need
peace and calm but i've got two babies
under the age of 18 months old sometimes
we just have
completely unrealistic needs and you
have to ask yourself a question what is
more important my need
or my relationship i need a tidy house i
love
tidy i love everything put away makes me
feel great i have a husband who
doesn't even notice he's left all the
cupboard doors open
all the kitchen cabinets open he loves
to cook
he's immensely messy and i realize that
his need is to enjoy
cooking without me saying oh look you've
got that on the floor why have you made
so much mess how come one tea bag
has managed to stay in every surface so
i just had to give up
my need to have a really tidy house and
to recognize that
having a happy marriage with a husband
who loves cooking
is actually a great gift and in my
relationship
i have to bring it back to you know what
is more
important here me and him and my need
for order
and tidiness and he has other needs and
i know that i don't meet
some of his needs he loves to go out
every night he's super social
i actually love to chill by sitting on
the sofa
and watching a movie and i love watching
things like
downton abbey and jane austen which
just leave him cold and he loves
watching documentaries with the history
of the world
and all kinds of science stuff that i
don't love either but we work it out
because i understand the third he meets
some of my needs fantastically well i'm
lucky to have him
i meet some of his needs amazing well
he's very lucky to have me but we both
understand okay i have to give this need
up and we both understand that other
needs
i needed so if i had a need to have a
husband go to the gym with me go
shopping with me that's not him
in my 33 years as a therapist
i have no doubt at all that my clients
are the unhappiest are the ones who are
looking for perfect i've got a list
i want someone who is perfect i always
find okay let's
imagine you found this perfect person
what you want what do they want if they
are
perfect don't you think they also want
perfect i recently
had a rock star's ex-wife in my office
and that all gone wrong she had a lot of
money said i need another rock star
but i want one 20 years younger than me
and i went why she said well i just i
want to be with the rocks i said but
where do you think that's going to go
you're 20 years older than him
don't you think you're just delaying the
enable of having a second
marriage go wrong don't pick someone 20
to 25 years younger than you
pick someone that you have shared
interest with
because when you look for perfect first
of all it doesn't exist you will never
find
mr or mrs perfect they don't
exist and in trying to find them you'll
be dissatisfied
you'll be sad you'll be disappointed you
know what you'll also be
lonely all of my clients trying to be
perfect and fine perfect are lonely
and dissatisfied and it's so unnecessary
all you have to do is understand
hey i'm a flawed person i can accept i
have flaws
and i'm with people all flawed and if i
was perfect i'd be lonely
my flaws make me real they make me
genuine they make me authentic
and that's a wonderful thing i always
remember one of my clients saying when i
saw my wife she was walking down the
street and her thighs rubbing together
it was the sexiest thing i'd ever seen
in my life
i'm like wow i wish every woman fighting
for a thigh gap could have heard him say
that was the sexiest thing another my
client
said my wife was working out she had
sweat running down her back and all
around her groin
it was so erotic i was so attracted to
this girl covered in sweat with wet hair
who would have thought that no makeup
working out
sweating damp hair red face and yet to
him
that was sexy so please don't try to be
perfect there
is no fairy tale there's real
life and real life is amazing you know
the best thing when you know that
someone
loves you for you when you're throwing
up because you're sick when you've got a
cold and your eyes are red and your hair
is matted
and they bring you coffee or tea and
tell you they love you then you know
that's the fairy tale oh you love
me just the way i am and i love you
and you'll be having a bad day and i
love you just as much maybe even more
because your vulnerability
makes me want to care for you and i've
worked with
many many models who feel gosh you know
i never want to disappoint someone that
isn't really me
ava gardner said every man i meet thinks
i'm
gilda sharon stones that every man
thinks i'm
katherine from basic instinct that isn't
me
they are always disappointed so many
supermodels and movie stars tell me
people are disappointed with me because
they think i'm this
role it's not me but imagine if you
don't
have to be perfect you can be you and
you're loved
guess what you don't get disappointment
guess what you don't worry about
you're disappointed in me when you can
be real
no one is disappointed in you and that
includes
you so remember the key
to a great relationship is how well the
conversation goes back
and forth how good you are recognizing
each other's needs and meeting as many
as you can
the key to a great relationship is do
you respect
and admire each other do you have sexual
chemistry
and best friend chemistry
nothing in there says hey are you
perfect for your partner because they
don't even want that
i've worked with models who are left
and their partners say oh it was like
dating a racehorse it was just
so much work and now my next partner is
just real and warm and genuine and
i didn't even want all that drama
so remember if your relationship now is
not working don't think well i better
stay in it because
i'm looking for the fairy tale you can
always
make your relationship better or leave
something that really doesn't work and
find
a better relationship when you stop
looking for something that isn't real
and become the real
lovable you you can find someone that
loves you because you're you
and you love them because they're them
and then you build this beautiful
flawed relationship together loving
in each other believing in each other
supporting each other not having to
worry about
your thighs or your height or the
number the number on your birthday but
the number on the scale the number
in your clothing label the number in
your bank account
those don't matter what matters is being
a real person
finding real love based on being real
and then it will last forever
because it's real and way number seven
the last one before very special bonus
clip
is be the source of happiness with
sadhguru
when people say that they are in love
they think they are an unconditional
love
but still in most of the cases it's
not working it doesn't lead to happiness
so sadhguru when is unconditional love
truly possible see
when you say love
your experience of love means you feel
certain sweetness of emotion within
yourself
either by looking at this person or this
person or this person we don't know who
stimulates this in you
it doesn't matter who helped you but
essentially it happened within you
isn't it yes
did it happen only within you or was it
in the air i'm trying to clear this air
combination of wood really it was in the
air
no it only happened within you maybe
what was happening within you was so
exuberant
you saw it everywhere you're in love you
thought the flowers bloomed for you the
birds are singing for you the clouds are
moving for you
huh all right i don't want to destroy
all the romance okay but
essentially it's happening within you
it's wonderful
that you are experiencing such sweetness
of emotion
stimulated by somebody you are using the
other person as a key
to open up an experience within you
essentially i'm asking you
why are you using the key when there is
no lock
when there is no door when there's no
any kind of barrier
it is just that you are a push start
machine
you know what's a push start machine if
you have owned an ambassador
25 years ago always you parked it on a
gradient like this
because morning two people have to push
it
if you park it like this nobody will
come your family will not come out of
the house
if it's like this somebody will come and
push it now all the cars
are self-start many of them remote start
what does it mean technological
upgradation you are an institute of
technology
all right i'm asking would you like to
upgrade your technology
that you're on self-start if you wake up
in the morning
you're overflowing with joy and love and
exuberance
by yourself you don't need anybody to
stimulate you
would you like to be a self-start
machine
then you must come to me
whoever is right now doing the love in
the air
it's fine with them you don't have to
tell them anything you say all right
it's okay but it's very important you're
a self-start machine
otherwise after some time
you try to extract happiness from the
other person
that is when these love of hats become
tedious and horrible
because you're trying to extract
happiness from the other person
no life should be like this when it
comes to joy
when it comes to love when it comes to
experience exuberance of life
you must be the source of this isn't it
you must be the source of this
well other things are shared in life
there are two ways
to enter into a relationship
one way is because you want to extract
something from somebody
another way is because you want to share
something with somebody
these are two ways if you're out to
share your life will be good
if you're out to extract when they close
the tap
it's going to get terrible and nasty you
have seen
people who thought their absolute lovers
how terrible it becomes for many of them
not because there's anything wrong with
them simply because you started off on
the wrong footing
thinking this person is the source of my
joy
no no no joy or misery the source is
within you
yes or no whether it's joy or misery
the source is within you it's for you to
decide
if you're a joyful human being they will
also want to be with you
if you're a misery they will endure you
for some time
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule
in what day what time and what place
you're going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below write down your single biggest
takeaway as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
do you have any relationship advice for
entrepreneurs
or nina yeah so so okay so
yes um
for me
i need i don't need to talk about stuff
so when i'm dealing with something i'm
an introvert so i need to go
i need to go inside and figure it out
talking about my problems unless
unless there's a solution like if i
think you can help me i'm going to talk
to you
but if it's something i don't think you
can help with me just
telling you about it does nothing for me
nina always wants to know what's
happening in my life in my day i don't
have a need to tell her
but i i have to tell her for our
relationship
and so involving the people
in your family into your business
doesn't mean they have to be involved
heavily like nina now
quit her job to join me on this thing
that we're doing together
otherwise she's not super involved in
what i'm doing day to day she had her
own job
but involving her to know what i'm going
through what
process and pain so that when i'm
sitting here like struggling and just
like trying to think of something
i'm not in my own world she kind of gets
what's going on
so if i have a youtube issue and i tell
her about it it's like do you want to go
home and like go fix it
like it's okay we'll we'll we'll
we'll stay and do our thing together but
at least she knows
enough about what's happened in my life
so it's not being completely shut out
so that was one that made a huge
difference um
just be able to communicate what's going
on
[Music]
if you want to change your life in 30
days for free check the link right below
me
and if you want six more ways to improve
your relationship click the video right
here
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe
i'll see you there